To produce a production ready version
of our site, we can skip the whole live
editing and watching, and include
the scripts distribution task instead.
Nothing easier than that.
Let's call the new task dist and include
the following tasks in that order.
Copy html.
Copy images.
Styles.
Lint.
And finally scripts-dist.
Try running the tasks
via gulp scripts-dist.
If gulp takes slightly longer, and
exists without opening the browser,
you're all set, and have a production
ready distribution in your dist folder.
Before we continue, one word of
advice regarding minification.
Minification on its own is great,
but GZIP is even more affective.
GZIP compresses the file before it
gets in, and out to the browser,
and the browser deflates it.
All of this happens transparently
in the background and
usually only requires a small
server configuration change.
Read more about GZIPing in the nodes,